So I'm going to tell you about something called matrix factorizations,
but the story starts with something I've studied in, in middle school.
And you probably did too. Do you remember, we, you, you thought about factoring,
so you could factor in things like X squared minus four.
And if you remember that X minus two, two is the square root of four.
That's the point times X plus,
and then maybe a little later you are allowed to replace four by the square of
another variable. So if you have X squared minus Y squared,
the same formula works because you have the square root of Y squared.
And thanks minus Y times X plus Y the advantage of that is you can plug
in any numbers you like for X and Y. And this will always be true. Uh,
you can also ask about square roots of polynomials like that.
So if you had X squared plus two X,
Y plus Y squared, then you could not only factor it.
You could find a square root.
So it's the product of two things that are equal it's X plus Y squared,
but there were plenty of things you couldn't factor.
The simplest one is something like X squared,
plus three couldn't factor it because you couldn't find a square root of minus
three, but if you put in complex numbers, then you can factor it.
So if you enlarge the domain of things, you accept as a fact variation,
then suddenly it becomes possible to factor.
And that's the kind of old story in mathematics.
If you want to solve an equation, like even something simple,
like three X minus one equals zero, can't solve that in integers.
So you invent rational numbers, fractions, and then you suddenly can solve that.
X is a third,
or if you said three X plus one equals zero,
and you'd have to know about negative numbers too. And for awhile,
negative numbers were sort of very strange things in mathematics and they got
ordinary and we are happy to use them. So this is a kind of old theme in there.
Mathematics. If you don't have enough tricks in your bag, put in a new trick,
the square root of minus one, well, I'll let you solve lots more equations.
Then you could have solved them before.
And that's a story that's gone on in mathematics since the Greek times, really,
and been very important and always as a kind of complaint that well,
that isn't real. It isn't the same thing. You know,
if solve and get a negative number, what could that mean in reality,
but people got over it and they discovered that negative numbers were just as
useful as positive numbers, or they could represent different kinds of things.
It's almost that necessity is the mother of invention. That's right.
And nature somehow follows along. Or, I mean, nature was ahead of us there.
I think so nature knew about complex numbers,
but they didn't bother to tell us for a long time.
And then we needed them for something.
And we realized that they were useful and they've, you know,
now are the basis of lots of physics and everything.
So they're really out there in nature,
even though they're called imaginary or complex. So there's a,
another story like this, which comes up in the invention of quantum mechanics.
Paul Adrian Dereck was one of the great physicists to the 20th.
And he was involved in the beginnings of quantum mechanics. As he worked,
he realized he needed to solve a problem like this,
which didn't seem to have a solution.
And the problem was about a complicated looking formula differential operator,
minus C squared times the second derivative with respect to time,
plus the sum of the derivatives with respect to the spatial coordinates.
So these squared let's say D X squared plus D squared,
D Y squared plus D squared, DZ squared.
So Dereck wanted not to solve this equation.
This has an important differential operator, but he wanted a square root of it.
That's a sort of weird thing to want because there is no square root,
which is a differential operator written like this. And if you think about it,
you can change coordinates. I won't bother to go through the change.
You need complex numbers and things,
but this is just like the formula T squared plus X squared,
plus Y squared plus Z squared.
So direct knew right away that finding a square root of this complicated looking
thing is the same as finding a square root of, of this simpler looking thing.
It's got four terms, but you can't find a square root.
You can't even find a factorization of it. In fact,
if you think about it for a moment, you don't see that.
So Dereck had to jump out of the realm of simple polynomials and
what he did was realized that you could factor this in a certain sense in
terms of matrices. And in fact,
he's famous for inventing matrix mechanics and quantum mechanics in quantum
mechanics. One way to represent a state is as a big matrix, in fact,
an infinite matrix, but finite ones are already interesting enough.
Professor.
So I'd take it the tool that he's about to pull from the tool bag to get him out
of his jam and matrices, but he didn't invent matrices. They were already known.
Just,
these were a big deal already in the 19th century when they were used for other
mathematical purposes. And they're used in all kinds of ways today,
they're everywhere in mathematics and physics and in all the applications of
mathematics. So this was brand new idea that direct head,
and it's an idea that's had legs and I'll tell you,
so how did he do it first? I have to remind you how,
what would it even mean to factor something in matrix?
You've got to multiply things to factor, right? So how do we multiply matrices?
Let me remind you. I'll do it with two by two matrix.
So suppose you have two matrices,
they could be matrices of numbers or matrices of polynomials,
and let's call the other one, a prime B prime,
C prime D prime matrix, of course,
is just an array of variables and where you're going to multiply them only when
they're square matrices of the same size.
So you do this by taking the rows of the first matrix and multiplying them by
the columns of the second matrix. So for example,
the upper corner of the product matrix is going to be gotten by taking the first
row of the first matrix in the first column.
So it's a times a prime plus B times C prime,
and then I'm going to do the same thing for the second entry on the top,
a B prime plus B D prime. And then on the bottom,
I'll use the bottom row of the first matrix,
a prime C plus C prime D and then finally
B prime, C plus D prime D. So that's a formula, it's a formula like any other,
the good thing about it is it has lots of the properties that ordinary
multiplication has,
but one property it doesn't have is that if you take matrices in the other
order, you don't get the same answer. They don't commute.
And that's because we use the rows of this matrix and the columns of that
matrix. So it's obvious that there's no reason why they should commute.
And in fact, they don't directs idea was first of all,
to factor this polynomial in terms of matrices,
I'm going to do a slightly simpler looking example,
but those of you who know about complex numbers will know that it's the same
example written in a different way. X, Y minus U V.
That's another falling Romeo in four variables, but it's it.
You can transform this into this with complex numbers.
And so how would you factor that in matrices? Well, here's the answer.
I'll just write it down. It's X,
Y U V times
Y X here and minus U and minus V
here.
So this is a formula that some people in the audience will surely recognize,
and it's a spray simple one. Direct, certainly knew it and knew how to use it.
Here's a polynomial on the left and a matrix on the right.
So what could that mean? Well, so this equality is wrong,
but what's true is that this is a diagonal matrix, X,
Y minus UV,
and then zero and zero and X, Y minus UV.
And I think of this as X,
Y minus UV of polynomial multiplied by the matrix,
which looks like one. You know, if you multiply something by one,
you get the same thing back in ordinary arithmetic.
So this is like the polynomial X, Y minus UV.
And that's the sense in which this is a matrix factorization,
and I can even do this with the,
getting a square root by another simple trick that Dirac also probably knew in
advance, which is what he really wanted, which is what he wanted.
He wanted the square root of the spelling Romeo.
So this requires a bigger matrices, no problem.
So let's call this matrix a and this matrix and B,
and then I'll make a bigger matrix by taking zero a,
this is now going to be a four by four, matrix B zero,
and multiplying it by the same thing,
zero a B zero. So that's the square of the matrix,
zero B zero squared. And that's equal to X,
Y minus UV times a bigger matrix. One,
one, one, one on the diagonal still it's an identity matrix.
So this counts indirects book as a square.
Because you can square root cause you can.
So as you can you square a matrix and you get something,
which is the personification and matrices of this polynomial direct was
satisfied with this. It served his purpose. He invented matrix mechanics,
quantum mechanics, peacefully went on. And that,
that was the sort of the end of the story.
That's the question, though.
It feels a bit like you've changed sports mid game though.
Like it's like you started playing baseball and then by the end you were playing
football cause you were using matrices, but so,
so have you not lost any meaning or usefulness by the way, that change of games.
Surprisingly not. This is another case where nature was ahead of us.
And nature said, well, really,
you should be working with matrices to begin with. And you just found that out.
So direct was happy. And as I say,
quantum mechanics is based on this idea of extending the domain of thought in
order to get some better results.
Where's it going since you've, you've been playing with it?
Yeah, actually I wrote a paper on this subject.
It's actually become my most quoted paper.
And I'll tell you why that is to the title of the paper is homological algebra
uncomplete intersections. It doesn't seem to have anything to do with this,
but it contains the theorem, which is a nice one,
which says essentially that you can factor any polynomial that even seemed
plausibly factor level in terms of matrices.
And if you don't exclude a sort of stupid idea,
then that becomes a trivial statement.
So of course you can factor any polynomial or anything in the world.
You can say F is equal to one times F that's
not an interesting factorization. You didn't learn anything from that.
And that's not the kind of factorizations we were doing before.
So I want to exclude polynomials and matrices that have ones in the
word numbers in them, and only look at things with her.
Paloma is of higher degree.
Then I can't factor the polynomial X it's a degree one.
And if you multiply Palomas with degree three and four,
you get upon them as degree seven. There's nothing you can do about it.
You can't factor X plus Y squared either for the same reason,
because you can't find things that multiply the X. So you have to exclude that.
So the theorem I proved is that any polynomial with no
constant or linear term linear means degree,
one can be factored as a product of
matrices with no constant terms,
no numbers in them. In other words.
Can you show me a few examples of, yes, I can do that one. No,
I can't do that one. Right?
Tell me a polynomial, right?
Pikes cubed us 79 Y squared
plus 34 X, Z.
Plus you just, anything? It doesn't matter. So I could,
and I can write down an algorithm which would produce matrix factorization of
whatever you want, or the machine will do it.
For me. Can you show me one? You can't do.
So you can't do X plus Y squared.
You can't do X plus anything,
but that's basically the only things you can do.
It sounds to me like you can't do a polynomial. If it has a variable,
like an X in it that isn't multiplied by another variable and is a power.
Right. It isn't multiplied by itself or another variable. Right.
So very volatile. Okay.
So the reason the X was okay here is because it was multiplied by a C, right?
That's right. Okay.
So actually the theorem applies to power series and lots of other things too.
And the, the restriction of not having a linear term or a constant term
has a different interpretation in power series, which is more natural in a way.
So this is, this is a true statement,
but it's not the most natural statement from a mathematician.
Direct, not saying that or good.
Question. I don't, and of course I can't ask him, I don't know the answer.
He's dead a long time already, but, uh,
it proving this depends on a theory of finite free resolutions in
which I'm an expert and have thought about a lot.
And I actually got to it by proving something different in that
theory.
So I proved that if you take a polynomial ring and factor
out upon an oatmeal,
then every free resolution becomes periodic of period
two. And the period two part really comes from a matrix factorization of that
polynomial. So thanks algorithmic way of producing the matrix factorization.
And there's more to it than that, of course, but that's the,
that was how I got to it.
Why is it your most cited paper? So.
It was, uh, it was already a nice paper.
I was very proud of it at the time I did it and people used it for this and that
it has something to do with a subject called Cohen Macaulay modules, um,
and representations of finite groups. So it,
it got out in the literature was used, but then in 2004,
a physicist discovered that he needed this general theorem
for the purpose of, uh, defining boundary conditions in string theory.
And string theory, of course, is a big deal.
And physicists tend to cluster in groups,
working on things so soon there were hundreds of references to this.
So that's why I became my most cited paper.
Have you become a bit of an expert on string theory now? Like if you research,
why they like it or have you just kind of said, all right,
if it makes you happy, go ahead. I don't care.
A mixture of the two, uh, actually a collaborator of mine, Irena paver.
And I worked on a generalization of this and we thought, well,
the string is to love this so much and maybe they'll love our generalization
too. That would be nice.
And so we talked to a bunch of physicists and they got them to give us days of
explanation. And at the end I understood a little more than I had before,
but I certainly didn't become a physicist.
I think that's a hard theory to get into if you're not steeped in,
in field theory to begin with.
What good does it, do you,
if a paper you wrote gets cited lots and lots of times.
Makes me pleased. That's all really, um, I,
I admit a stage of my career where it doesn't really matter to me in career
terms at all. Uh, but it's,
it's nice to know that someone is using them. You know,
mathematics has a pretty small audience base, 80,
your videos have vastly extended the audience space.
But if I look at the colleagues who would be natural
candidates for using this theorem, it might be in the hundreds,
but it's not in the millions, certainly. Maybe it's not in the thousands.
And so having more people interested in one's work, that feels good.
So citations a lot, your video views.
That's right, exactly. Exactly.
How many citations does it had? I.
Don't, I, I don't know. I haven't looked, um, my,
my book on community algebra has the most citations and that's in the thousands,
but that's, that's a lot from any mathematical work.
Here's a good compass ruler meant just a straight edge, no markings on his role.
This one has markings, but I'm gonna use it anyway. I won't use the markings.
Here's a nice circle, drawn with a compass and the old style. So one,
two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
15, 16, 17, 18,
19 2021.
So I made a 21 gun by accident.